hey guys why didn't the vault dweller go
to the birthday party because he had
nobody to go in
[Music]
and he does it's beautiful Tony gonna
burn my troubles away
I'm go away
[Music]
Wow
hey guys welcome to a new episode of the
fallout 4 show there are wastelanders
out there that are working tirelessly
tinkering with the inner workings of
Fallout and today we'll be looking at
some of the most intriguing or deranged
mod creations to have already been
created for Fallout 4 our first mod is a
higher settlement budget by grim tech
when the radiation storms roll in you'll
need somewhere for shelter to keep the
rads at bay and of course no good mayor
leaves their settlers out in a cold
night after being robbed be tackled by a
mini nuke wielding super mutant it's a
good change of pace to return to your
settlement and play a post-apocalyptic
version of The Sims Fallout 4s default
settings means that the settlements can
only hold a certain amount of building
pieces meaning there may not be room for
your dream scrap scraper but this simple
script will allow you to really go
overboard with your architectural
distraction to run it open the games
console click your workshop and type of
bat settlement which tricks your game
into thinking you're living in an empty
plot when in reality you really just
want to finish that awesome treehouse
you started in sanctuary fooling the
game to let you build your heart's
content it's really the only way that
you'll get to build the badass forts and
castles that your 8-year old self would
truly be envious of now the only thing
left to do is scavenge every single
piece of junk in all of the wasteland so
you can actually have enough scrap to
build your new Empire of screws and
sheet or spawn spawning them works too
maude number two is the enhanced
wasteland preset which we briefly
featured on last week's episode fallout
4 is a beautiful looking game especially
in comparison to stock colored green
that covered most of Fallout 3's
wasteland but that doesn't mean you
can't really push the visuals to their
limits adding a touch more vibrancy to
the environment makes the world feel
less washed out and can really make your
time in Boston feel a little bit
brighter I mean just because the
Commonwealth was bathed in nuclear fire
doesn't mean it can't look its best the
mod page lists its features as adding
ambient light depth of field FX AAA CA
and luma sharpen lifts gamma gain
vibrance curves sepia dither which is a
lot of confusing words that I don't
fully understand but one thing I do know
is that it makes Fallout 4 look even
lovelier than it did before
think about the mods that released years
after new Vegas came out they completely
change the look and feel of the game and
we don't even have official mod tools
for Fallout 4 yet so just think about
the eye candy we can expect down the
line
and speaking of eye candy with modern
number 3 you can look your absolute best
whilst also having some modicum of
protection your sharpest tux won't do
much against a 308 round but fear not
you can keep safe and still turn heads
at tonight's soiree although perhaps for
the wrong reasons there's a huge number
of armor pieces in the world of Fallout
4 but all of them fit as well as your
favorite pair of tighty whities I found
myself disappointed after realizing my
awesome new piece of armor couldn't
accommodate the trusty old equipment I
found through the wastes this mod does
fix that even if it does do it in a
clumsy ugly fashion is fashion for more
armor slots model lets you wear anything
with anything whilst it may not look the
best with textures and models melting
into each other like your outfit was
covered in oh so rare adhesive and you
were rolled through your garden shed
there is however something very
empowering about wearing your toughest
armor with a shiny red dress and heels
something just feels right when the
rounds from your laser rifle match
you're fetching new crimson evening gown
best buy the mod is the masks and
helmets which seem to merge together
surprisingly well which is more than can
be said for some of the armor
combinations but I suppose nobody's
perfect admittedly modern before isn't
exactly the most exciting pick of the
bunch but it's extremely useful the
fallout 4 configuration tool that you
tweak the games your heart's content
with just a few clicks instead of having
to edit those tricky ini files giving
you the ability to change your field of
view the rate in which the game runs an
autosave activating mouse acceleration
and game pads disabling the intro video
and all of that nasty gore as well as
making changes to performance parameters
like CPU priority particles and draw
distances you can even use it to make
all your menus and boy lights as
colorful as you like and for the clumsy
amongst us the mud will automatically
backup any files in case you're like me
and accidentally break your game an
increased field of view can make the
game more enjoyable for those that
suffer from gaming and juice motion
sickness and the many performance
enhancements the mod offers may allow
fallout 4 to make better use of all
those shiny new PC components you saved
up all that pocket money for what's your
favorite song in Fallout 4 well for mod
creator train whiz it must be the 5
stars atom bomb baby
well maybe he just decided it would be
fun to launch exploding infant from a
shoulder-mounted Kapil ah see what I did
there
anyway it's simple yet hilarious mod
replaces the model for the fat man's
mini nukes with that of your in-game son
Sean like any beloved virtual parent I'm
sure you want to be close to a strange
child but I don't recommend it in this
instance it's rather disturbing to see
your floating newborns scattered around
the wasteland while still hunting for
loot
although not as disturbing as entering
vats the single flown from your fat man
and fly towards Angry deathclaws before
exploding into a mushroom cloud as if
someone ignited the poor kid's diaper
these tiny children they acting to be
the same have damage as a regular mini
nuke if you don't count the
psychological damage you'll be doing
through enemies as you sling your
offspring across the sky over the course
of recording footage to talk about this
unique mod I fired the fat man launcher
at least a hundred times I guess that
means I won't be winning any father of
the Year awards so those are five of the
most interesting useful or insane mods
out there for fallout 4 right now and
with the official fallout 4 mod tools'
still months away
I am truly excited to see what the
creative and slightly deranged can
create for those of you that have
watched the fallout 4 show before you
will know that we'd like to end each
episode by taking a look at some of the
community made submissions whether it be
art cosplay your interesting settlements
or all of the above so today we've got a
few things we can take a look at first
up is a painting of the ever so
enigmatic Valentine a character from
fallout 4 and beautifully done painting
reminds me of the old detective novels
if you haven't found Valentine in the
game yet I highly recommend you err you
go hang out with him because he's
definitely one of the better companions
and you get to hang out with a cool guy
in a trench coat and a fedora which is
let's be honest it's quite a hard look
to pull off next we've got a very
impressive Brotherhood of Steel cosplay
hanging out with a one and only vault
boy it's always surprising how amazing
these cosplays look where I can't
actually dress myself properly in the
morning but there's people out there
making full suits
power armor and glowing green has no
rifles excellent stuff if I came across
you in the wasteland
I would definitely enter vats and run
away and we have a prop master
repainting his pit boy because let's be
honest those of you with the pip-boy
edition as cool as they are they do look
a bit like they've just rolled off the
production line and let's be honest if
you're wandering the wastes they're not
gonna look brand spanking new are they
so this talented individual has
repainted and added some few details to
make the people who look like it's
actually wandered through the wastes of
Boston and a vault dweller would be
proud to wear it on his rugged
battle-hardened wrist if you have any
submissions make sure you tweet them at
us with hash tag gs4 I'd be really
interested to see some of the
settlements that people are making and
there's been a lot of posts on Reddit
and some of the forums about people
making giant bases I spend a lot of my
time with the settlements Devon for now
so I'd be really interested to see some
of that so make sure you send that to us
until the next episode I've been your
host Dave Jew you can find me on twitter
at a regular dave make sure you like the
video and subscribe to the fallout 4
show and i will see you next time
wasteland
[Music]
the bow lip sweat now feels swell
but you got its a beautiful tone even
gonna burn my truck